Throughout history, map makers have helped us discover where we were,...
...and where we were going.
But while it may seem like every corner of the world...
...has been surveyed and charted,...
...navigating the world of indoor spaces can still be somewhat vexing.
A map may help you get from your house to the airport...
...but oftentimes it leaves you at the front door.
Many places provide a "You are here" directory.
But if you don't know where "here" is in relation to "there,"...
...you can quickly become lost...
...in a veritable labyrinth of unknown twists and turns.
This is why the mapping folks at Google added indoor Google Maps.
Now it's easy to figure out where you are,...
...orient yourself and even know what floor you're on.
Best of all, this feature now appears...
...right within Google Maps on Android devices,...
...meaning you can plan your trip the whole way through...
...and never worry about getting lost in the wrong department again.